para taiwán el miedo la invasión china
no es nuevo lleva rondando más de siete
décadas y por ello afirman que están
preparados ahora que parece estar más
cerca la diferencia entre el poderío
militar de china y taiwán es evidente
beijing cuenta con el tercer ejército
más fuerte del mundo mientras que taipei
posee el 21º pero taiwán lleva décadas
preparándose ante un posible ataque
chino para proteger nuestra patria es
responsabilidad de nuestros soldados no
importa cuál sea la situación actual
constantemente nos estamos capacitando y
acumulando experiencia para ser mejores
fans el plan operacional one contempla
la defensa ante una invasión de hasta un
millón de soldados chinos y se basa en
dos puntos la implicación militar de los
23 millones de taiwaneses y la ventaja
geográfica taiwán sólo puede invadir
sede forma naval o aérea pero la isla
cuenta con numerosas bases militares y
con la ventaja de tener aguas poco
profundas a su alrededor y un territorio
muy escarpado que haría que la invasión
fuera posible solamente por dos puntos
uno en la parte norte y al suroeste y
estas zonas son precisamente las más
protegidas por taiwán un contexto que
desata muchos interrogantes para china
ya que esta operación podría ser muy
costosa especialmente si no se realiza
de forma rápida y masiva a ello hay que
añadir la incógnita sobre si ante un
ataque chino eeuu estaría dispuesto a
defender a su aliado una cuestión que
cambiaría por completo el conflicto